hello thank you for joining us today my
name is Colonel Eadie academic segment
manager disease research and toxicology
at Agilent Technologies a leader in life
sciences clinical research diagnostics
and applied chemical markets I am
delighted to welcome you to laborat
seventh annual cancer research and
oncology educational virtual event the
world has seen some great strides in
cancer research including better ways to
diagnose and treat patients this forum
will influence future work in this field
sharing the common goal of advancing the
management and approaches for early
detection and prevention of cancer
cancer research on oncology 2019 brings
together relevant experts providing
opportunity to discuss scientific
questions and challenges the agenda will
be comprised of 16 thought-provoking
discussions covering the topics from
tumour drug resistance to precision
oncology and much more to keynote
speakers will be among the highlights
Ernesto Diaz forties assistant adjunct
professor in the department of
pediatrics hematology at UCSF will kick
off the first day identifying novel
therapies presenting a promising
preclinical study on acute leukemia and
a Chu Ernest talk will focus on eight
actions that individuals can take to
reduce their cancer risk
dr. Hawke is vice president division
head for cancer prevention at MD
Anderson Cancer Center the conference
continues the interactive platform
tradition offering live streaming
webcasts and a virtual lounge we hope
you use this opportunity to collaborate
with each other in this unique
environment exchange knowledge and
promote ideas for the future be sure to
visit the exhibit hall and explore
showcased technologies at the booths and
engage with sponsor representatives in
real time on their latest innovations on
behalf of the organizing committee
coupled with the invited speakers and
sponsors lab roots is pleased
to bring you this event sharing
outstanding achievements and future
trends to enrich Cancer Research enjoy